à castanet déjà avec quand j'ai déjà dit
je comprends pas ce qu'ils une potion
montiel sans rigoler il s'est réveillé
en milieu d'année frères les sautes il a
su qu'il a n'est vraiment pas que porte
parole du gouvernorat et ceni faut quand
même que je travaille à la mouche al
oula parce que ce n'est pas pour faire
une vidéo gag surprendre va-t-on de
chômage s'est dit c'est bon ça m'est
déjà arrivé une fois sur place j'ai pas
refaire la même sur ses frontières il
est reparti mais l'animal une petite
crise identitaire je me racontais
l'histoire de cette saison genre à la
can en plus l'accent calmant après le de
merde donc je fais mon film ce soir très
beau fils est magnifique cette fois non
j'adore cinéma paradiso très beau fils
n'avait été noir et bien sûr c'est bling
site magnifique j'adore
bon c'est bon vous a pas demandé de
juger des films ici à la crise
identitaire
alors on va y arriver tout benhaim avait
besoin et je lui dis médaille à un
moment il ya eu trop de succès trop vite
c'est comme si elle sortait d'un thé
pourrait à la manger trop de l appel à
des gestions d'audience les gens me
reconnaissent comme ça l'a dit je vais
perdre trois mois je met au vert elle a
fait trois soirs trois fois son journal
par en plus qu'en phase aller à la
laitue et pour pousser
est ce que je pourrais en dire ce que tu
manges je te rappelle en fait pour
l'argent
d'autres sports on a compris où il va
dire quand même que vous avez été
absolument adorable se faisait dit cyril
là c'est un peu trop il ya dix ans voilà
je voudrais un peu levé le pied parce
que je trouve qu'il faut aussi savoir
prendre de la distance et vous avez dit
écoute c'est toi qui décides voilà que
la maison et la porte est ouverte
tu tu reviens quand tu veux et si tu as
envie voilà il a quoi content et il y
avait quelque chose à d'autres
chroniqueurs est ouverte
6e et 6e
j'espère qu'ils me regardent et ben haim
aujourd'hui elle est heureuse elle est
reparti du mal car l'air franchement
benzema parce que voilà j'avais besoin
nouveau d'avoir envie je travaille à la
bien c'est le respect johnny hallyday et
tu sais dit des crises crise identitaire
ta d'aimer les gens ils pensent que tu
l'a viré et comme noah il me disait
aussi rires ça va être tout à fait prêt